brian is in Austin Texas hey Brian how
are you hey Dave leasure to talk to you
sir
you too sir what's up not much it's
funny that you mentioned that smart
conference because that is what I asked
my mom for for Christmas this year so
we'll see if if she comes through in the
clutch
very cool we'll see if she still knows
Santa Claus yeah I sure hope so my
question for you today is my wife and I
are paying off the last bit of our debt
it's a big chunk it's 45 K at the two
car note 25 on my truck 20 on her Nissan
robe and we've also enlisted the help of
a financial planner and it's a guy that
I just met with here in Austin and he
recommends he understands the whole Dave
Ramsey concept he gets attacking debt
but he says why not put money in the
market where it can earn say 6% and and
use the money that you were going to
take and apply towards debt and where
that debt is actually only at like 3%
yeah you know you need a new financial
planner this guy's an ignoramus and I
want your backup on that so what should
i what should I come back with you don't
need to come back with anything except
you're fired
okay yeah you got the wrong guy
I mean I'm not gonna try to convince
this idiot of stuff the bottom line is
this the answer to your question but not
how to address him with it don't address
him with it don't hire people that are
this dumb but the answer is pretty
simple this is standard crap in the
financial world now what kind of idiot
would tell you to go borrow on your car
to invest in the stock market
that's moronic it is moronic I mean
that's just ridiculous and that's
basically what he's saying because this
is the exact same math is if you went
and took out a car loan in order to
invest in his mutual funds that he wants
to sell you or whatever the crappy
selling you over there but that's just
dumb so here's the reason that that
clicks in your brain when I set it in
Reverse when I say it in reverse and you
take a paid-for car and you go borrow on
the car versus not paying off
the car and putting the money in the
market which is the same math back and
forth it's still a balance sheet issue
and so but but the reason that it it
clicks in there is there's I always say
we measure math with our brain and risk
with our heart and when I say it
backwards like that and I say well
that's moronic you go yeah it's moronic
because I made you think with your heart
not just your brain you measured you
suddenly measured risk is what you did
and risk is not in his formula and by
the way if you had a sophisticated
mathematical formula when you were doing
your investment analysis it would
include a risk factor to it does that
make sense it doesn't and you didn't
have any math in there for risk
whatsoever and you put risk and you put
risk into your life when you borrow
money 100% and the more money you borrow
the more risk you have now actually the
weird thing is Brian in the financial
world in our formal training that we get
when those of us that study finance like
I've got a four year degree in finance
and that kind of thing we're taught to
adjust for risk but never on the subject
of debt we just say well don't compare
this aggressive growth stock mutual fund
with this regular growth stock mutual
fund because it's more volatile and
there's actually a thing you can use
it's a major risk called the beta which
is how far off of the S&P it is how much
more volatile than the S&P it is the
higher the beta the bigger the risk in
other words that makes sense right it
means it means it's that much more
volatile than the S&P is and you can
mathematically use an inverse equation
and adjust for risk to compare that more
volatile fund with a less volatile fund
and you don't compare the returns apples
to apples you compare them risk adjusted
but you don't compare that risk adjusted
in your equation your equation was oh
you're making money in the market that's
more than you make on the car there was
nothing in there for risk that's why I
said it's moronic
and it's naive it's primitive and it's
what half the stupid people in the
financial world use that's why it's so
dumb but boy you see eighth-grade math
teachers and crap like this writing
stuff on these stupid websites that are
act like they're supposed to know what
they're doing
and they've never had any basic training
in this stuff and they don't put a they
don't assign risk to debt at all and so
their ability to crunch the numbers goes
away so now you needed to get a
different guy if you're gonna start
doing if you're when you're ready to
start investing and you're not ready to
start investing until you finish baby
step two which is man baby step three
maybe step two is you get the cars paid
off baby step three as you finish the
emergency fund and then baby step
forwards you put 15 percent of your
income into retirement and find someone
that it aligns with the program you're
gonna do now if you're not gonna do this
stuff I teach that's fine go with
whoever you want but don't try to get an
advisor to tell you to do one thing and
you're trying to do the stuff we teach
us another thing get people that are in
line with your beliefs in the direction
that you're gonna go and then you'll get
consistent advice and so forth that's
why you go you know you get a smart
investor Pro and they'll advise you but
you're not ready for that yet not till
you get these cars paid off or sell them
let's see if they're weighing you down
you got a lot of card debt I mean maybe
you need to sell them or one of them I
don't know but I'm with you let's get
rid of card debt and then let's build
that emergency fund and then let's start
investing hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
you
[Music]